is the first of um four lectures on
networks and economics uh matt is gonna
speak uh today and tomorrow and then
great thanks and thanks the organizers
and
pleasure to be here so
as i mean said i'm going to talk about
networks and economics and today it'll
be actually networks and game theory so
it'll be pretty much purely
game theory and then tomorrow will be
more on learning
and mod simple models of learning
and just in terms of putting this in
perspective part of the reason and
social scientists are interested in in
networks and graphs is that uh
understanding how people interact and
understanding their decisions and
behaviors depends heavily on
understanding the patterns in which they
interact
and
we've seen that this morning in terms of
you know diffusion and and contagion
processes
we'll talk a little bit more tomorrow
about learning processes
these are processes that are somewhat a
strategic in the sense that they don't
involve people making correlated
decisions or interdependent decisions
whereas a lot of peer effects involve
making predictions about how other
people are going to behave so whether or
not you want to adopt a new technology
or whether you want to speak a certain
language depends on whether other people
around you are speaking that language or
whether they're adopting that technology
and so that produces certain patterns of
behaviors and that's what i'm going to
spend most of the time on today
so peer influence and choices and
behaviors you care about
peers act and this you know in quotes
this is
more recently people start talking about
complex contagion and so forth
the idea here is that you've got these
interacting systems which produce
thresholds which make the analysis
different from
processes that are going to be
a little bit more
straight dynamic um in in certain ways
and we'll say more about that as we go
along
okay uh pure effects
there's lots of different ways in which
people affect each other
information we learn from people around
us opportunities we get from people
around us whether or not you have a
chance to get an interview for a job
whether or not you get recommended for a
job depends on you know your advisor
there's all kinds of things that depend
on the networks
but what we're going to focus most of
our time on today is these last two
which is the idea that that norms
traditions cultures um behavior
are are dependent on what other people
are doing there's complementarities in
those behaviors and
coordinating using the same technology
etc depends on what other people are
doing
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
presume that people are
novices to game theory i know that's
very wrong for some of you and probably
correct for for many others so there'll
be zero assumptions about people's
previous knowledge of game theory and
i'll try and make it self-contained on
that dimension but please you know stop
me if anything doesn't seem perfectly
clear so we'll start with a very special
case but it's one that has lots of
examples associated with it so people
are either choosing to adopt a
technology choosing one or not
they're choosing to become educated
they're choosing not to become educated
they're choosing to speak a certain
language or not so it's zero one choices
and the payoff depends on how many
neighbors are choosing the action and
what your own
um you know how many neighbors you have
and then what your own decision is so
this is a
you know a special case but it's it's a
important special case so each person
chooses an action in zero one and then
you're going to consider situations
where the payoffs we're going to have a
special kind of payoff to this so each
person is going to get some benefit from
from making this choice which depends on
what their degree is so how many friends
do i have what my choices and then this
m n of i is what's the number of people
in my neighborhood in the graph how many
friends do i have who are also taking
this action so if i'm going to try and
uh you know learn to play a certain
video game how many of my friends how
many friends do i have and then how many
of them are actually playing the video
game
more people playing that video game
makes it more likely that i want to play
that video game myself okay so that's
the basic structure of these kinds of
preferences and then we want to
understand the behaviors
so let's start with uh you know a few
examples
really simple one let's take some graph
there's some network each one of these
is a person they're making a choice
they're either going to adopt this new
technology or not
and
suppose that the payoffs are such that a
person prefers to adopt the new
technology if at least 40 of their
friends do so it's a relatively good
technology they don't need half their
friends they just need 40 to adopt it um
and then the question is what would
actually happen on this graph
okay so we can say well there's you know
a bunch of different possible outcomes
of stable points that could eventually
happen on this graph so if we look for
an equilibrium point this would be one
these three people adopt nobody else
does
that each one of these has at least 40
percent of their friends adopting so
they're all happy to take the technology
up none of their uh these other people
have fewer than 40
so that's an equilibrium okay so that's
one equilibrium
when you look at this graph there's many
equilibria right so here here's another
equilibrium
and there's going to be a bunch of them
so this is a game um
here in this particular example of
complementarities this person's willing
to choose one if and only at least some
fraction of neighbors do in this case
the it was 40
so here
if you look at the utility one way to do
this would be we normalize the utility
of not taking the adoption to zero
one payoff that would give this kind of
behavior is just look at the fraction of
my friends and then the payoff to
adopting is fraction of my friends
adopting minus 0.4 okay that would give
you payoffs that would yield this there
could be lots of different payoffs
different benefits and costs to this
game that would yield this kind of
behavior where the threshold be 40
okay
so um a nash equilibrium
in terms of this game so think of people
people are making choices in this case
it's a zero one choice so each person
has an action space that they can either
choose a zero or one
they're making a choice so each person's
choosing this x i either they're zero or
one
and they're getting some payoff from
this which is based on their own payoff
and the payoff of the others so the
definition of a nash equilibrium is just
a point such that we're going to specify
what everybody in the society does and
each person is making the best possible
choice given the choices of the others
so their act their payoff from choosing
the action they're choosing is at least
as good as they could from changing
their their um decision
okay is that clear
okay so that's the basic nash
equilibrium and we're going to be
looking at those in this
talk today
okay so if we look back at that graph we
had before
that there's a bunch of different
equilibria to that
where
everybody who adopts has at least 40 of
their friends adopting all the people
who don't have fewer than 40 percent of
their friends adopting there's a lattice
to those equilibria so the set of
equilibria in that particular game form
a lattice this is the lattice for that
particular network and for that
particular um threshold okay
okay so that's one kind of game that's a
prevalent game um so lots of pure
effects have this kind of feature that
the more of my friends take the action
the more i want to take it
that you yeah say
everybody who has adopted it has at
least 40 percent everybody who doesn't
has less but that was not the definition
of the clip it was that if i would
change
would it get better which is a different
notion so this doesn't show to me yet
right right so so if we go back to this
payoff here so let's suppose that this
is the payoff function
so if anybody in this and said take one
of these
these particular equilibria
change where this person they have um 40
they have half of their friends taking
the action so if they changed so right
now they're getting a positive payoff if
they change their action to a zero they
will get a negative payout or a zero
payoff
so each one of these people has a
positive payoff from taking it
each one of these people if they changed
they would get a negative payoff right
because the fewer than 40 percent so if
we go back to that definition
um with that 40 threshold in in this
case if anybody if anybody else here any
of these
non-green nodes change to be in green
they would get a negative payoff
so they would they would not want to do
that and the green nodes are getting a
strictly positive payoff none of them
wants to change
yeah so in this particular case
these are all equilibrium according to
that nash equilibrium definition
yes
yeah so so when i say a lattice of
equilibria a lattice is going to be as
set of objects
such that when you look at pairs of
objects you can order them and so here
let's suppose that we just look at we
look at the set of people taking the
actions we just code that as a vectors
these vectors of zeros and ones
and here this is a vector of all zeros
okay nobody's taking the action
up here is a vector of all ones
everybody's taking the action
and these lines indicate that we've
increased in the fact that the vector is
increased so this one is a bigger vector
than this one
this one's a bigger vector than this one
so each one of these is a bigger vector
than the one down here and a lattice is
such that if you take any set of
equilibria there's always something
which is at least as big as it and
something which is at least the smallest
part of it so this is a complete i mean
it's a finite lattice so it's going to
be complete but this is a lattice nice
lattice
so the join and myth operations are
faking the union and intersection
exactly exactly and so here you can see
you know and there's some interesting
ones here for instance there's sort of
an extra equilibrium
um
here
you can you can have these two alone be
in equilibrium or you can have these
five b equilibrium you can't have these
three separately from this to the
equilibrium
so the lattice is a little bit
asymmetric in this
particular example
so it's an interesting lattice in some
ways i have one mathematical question in
this uh
look at these ledges is it clear that we
will have a unique maxima maximum yes
exactly so the nice thing about a
lattice is it has a
unique maximum point and a unique
minimum point so it's a complete lattice
so there's a well-defined maximum and a
well-defined minimum point and then for
any set there's a maximum and you can
find a point which is uh least upper
bound and a greatest lower bond
it's not true for any lattice it's true
in this finite set um we have it's a
complete lattice so so there'll be a
theorem that in games of complements um
the excessive equilibrium will be a
complete madness in this in these
game on a network with these
complementarities the set of equilibria
will be completed so
you mean that it's a you need lower
bound transitioning up
i know so completeness means take any
any set of equilibria
there exists a well-defined least upper
bound for that set so for instance if i
take these two equilibria this is the
least of the bonds
so pick any set of equilibria and you
can find something which is the least
ever bound to it and a greatest lower
other questions
okay so so games of compliments have
lots of different possibilities and
another part of you know what's
interesting about things going viral
sometimes things don't spread you don't
get you know and good technology doesn't
spread at all other times it spreads
widely so this kind of multiplicity is a
fact of nature and understanding that
there's multiplicity and understanding
what these look like can allow us to you
know for instance set policies and say
okay look you know this is a good
technology but we're stuck here we want
to get here how do we get there right so
that's the kind of thing that the reason
we're interested in these kinds of
things from an economist point of view
is you know how can we understand where
we got stuck and why we got stuck there
and can we influence things
okay
so another example
so um which is much less well-behaved
is what's known as a best shot public
school
public goods game and so let me just
explain what this kind of game is
so imagine
the simple example is
you buy a book
okay if you buy a book you can read the
book
if your friend has a book the same book
you can borrow it from your friend and
you don't have to pay the price for the
book okay so think of of a product where
you can either buy it directly by
yourself at some cost or you can borrow
it from a friend
and so what you would
in terms of your payoffs there's a
benefit to reading the book there's a
cost to reading the book
and in this case
i would prefer to buy it if none of my
friends have the book so there's a book
i want to read i'll buy it if nobody if
none of my friends do but if one of my
friends has it i'd prefer not to buy the
book i'd prefer to borrow it okay we'll
go we'll go through the payoffs a little
later but just you know it's pretty
direct to see you know here i want to do
it if none of my friends are active i
want to be active i want to buy the book
if one of my friends buys the book i
don't want to that's what's known as a
best shot public goods game so there's
benefits from other people taking the
action so here if you start thinking
about equilibria here's an equilibrium
to this game okay these people buy the
book
their friends free ride so any one of
these other people can borrow the book
from from one of these
all these people have no friends that
have the book
right so they're all going to buy the
book
this is actually what's in graph theory
is known as a maximal independent set so
the the equilibria of a best shot public
goods game are equal to the maximal
independent sets of the graph
so so here there's a set of independent
nodes no no two of them are connected
and it's maximal in the sense that you
know everybody here already is connected
to somebody and these people are
connected to people who haven't bought
the book so that's all stable
okay
so this kind of game here's another
equilibrium does not have a lattice
structure
so it's much worse behaved in terms of
its mathematics lattices are very nice
objects it's easy to find lower bounds
you can take intersections and as i mean
we're saying you know intersections and
unions will make the lattice structure
very easy it's easy to find these
equilibria it's much nicer object some
mathematically these kinds of objects
are trickier and in fact you know
obviously finding the full set of
equilibria on a graph here is an np hard
problem um and and not in a in a hard
sense
okay so example of the best shot
you could say okay payoff of if i don't
take the i don't buy the book that's
action zero
one if someone in my neighborhood
is has bought the book so if at least
one person has bought the book i get a
one
a zero if nobody has
and then if i buy the book i get the one
from reading it but i pay the cost c
okay so that would be an example of a
best shot public goods but there could
be many other different payoffs that
would correspond to these kinds of games
so these are two examples of games on
networks
and here this you know best shot public
goods are the maximum independent set so
independent set set of nodes such that
no two nodes are linked to each other in
the set maximal every node in n is
either in s or linked to a node in s the
equilibria here are exactly a maximum
independent set
okay um
okay so these are some basic definitions
and examples now i want to talk about
strategic complements and substitutes
and sort of i think this is the
important conceptual meat of what i'm
going to talk about and sort of defining
this and i'll do it very in very simple
games where we're just doing these zero
one choices
and so
what are the first concept externalities
which is sort of the bread and butter of
economics what does externality mean
means that other behaviors affect my
utility or welfare so whether or not
somebody else is buying this book
affects my welfare
whether or not somebody else smokes
affects my welfare whether else somebody
else is making noise late at night so
other people's decisions and actions
affect me and game theory is the the
fact that their decisions their actions
not only affect my utility or welfare
but affect the relative payoffs to
different things so i want to change
what i do in response to what other
people are doing okay so externalities
mean they affect me and the interesting
part of game theory is they affect me
differently depending on what action i'm
taking
and and we'll go through some examples
here
so let's think about these strategic
substitutes this is like the um best
shot public goods game this was the case
friend does not buy the book if i buy it
i'm going to get a benefit minus the
cost
friend buys it doesn't matter if i
bought it i'm still paying the benefit
minus the cost
um here if the friend doesn't buy it
i get a zero and if i don't buy it and
then if i buy it
if i don't buy it and the friend buys it
i get a b
okay so where's the externality here
the externality is the fact that the
friend's decision
affects my payoff when i don't buy it
right so that's where the externality is
and here it's a pause what's known as a
positive externality
so the friend buying it improves my
welfare
so i'm getting a better payoff when they
buy it than what i didn't
okay
so that's a positive um
externalities sorry
so here
so just in terms of the
equilibrium structure the reason that
this was a hard game to analyze was that
we have sort of this reversal the friend
doesn't buy it i want to buy it friend
buys it i don't want to buy it right so
you've got this mismatch in
behaviors and that's what causes the
equilibrium structure to be more
complicated
okay so that's strategic substitutes
strategic complements
when we look to say um you know i get a
benefit of of playing learning to play a
game or adopting this technology if my
friend does as well
then here if the friend doesn't i invest
in this game or technology i just pay
the cost c i don't have anybody to play
it with they play it i get the benefit
minus the cost
if i don't invest at all i get zeros so
here the externality is is on the top so
the difference between that those two
games was where this externality was
it's a positive externality but in this
case it's on my my decision to to play
or buy or adopt in the other case it was
on the other decision
okay
questions about this concept okay so
that's strategic compliments and we'll
be more explicit about this in a minute
um
when we
talk about and producing a good and
polluted environment we often talk about
the externality but
yeah so um in the network setting
usually what we're thinking of is the
people around you know we define as the
friends or the people in the graph as
the people who actually impact me
more generally it could be if we're
thinking about something like you know
pollution uh you know a factory
polluting then that decision is gonna
impact possibly a whole large group of
people and so you could put that into a
network but more generally when we think
about externalities you know the early
literature on externalities was about
big function questions and things like
that but externalities are very much at
play are the things that make most of
economic decisions interesting so
they're playing the micro scale as well
as the macro scale
and and they're sort of the you know
really what defines game theory without
these externalities
it's this simple signal person decision
making because nobody else affects my
payoff you know it doesn't matter what
other people are doing so this is where
all the action is
so one other thing you know people sort
of think okay
um
you know when
you can do this with negative
externalities as well so you can have a
strategic game of compliments with
negative externalities
so here's an example um doping
so think of people in athletic
competition and there's a possibility
that they can take drugs dope to cheat
okay
so here if your competitor doesn't cheat
you don't cheat let's normalize the
payoff to zero so it's an even match
now if your competitor doesn't and you
dope
um there's a benefit to winning minus
the cost of doping and and here let's
assume that this is a person who doesn't
have moral costs to doping so they're
just getting a positive benefit from
doping okay so they would choose if
their competi competitor doesn't they
would choose to build
okay where's the negative externality
the negative externality is if they
don't dope
and their
competitor does
they're going to lose and there's some
loss
right and it could be a large loss so
effectively they're going to be
ineffective they have no chance in the
competition
they get a negative payoff if their uh
competitor dopes and they don't
and so then if they if the competitor
dopes and they do dope
um they're going to get a minus c here
so they're going to end up with a
negative payoff compared to what they
could have gotten if they both didn't
dope because now they're back in a
stalemate but they're both doping
but this is a game where there's a
negative externality to it doping
actually hurts me
um but we end up with an equilibrium
where everybody dopes
okay or tests you know unless you're
testing and do other kinds of things and
unless you have moral reasons for not
doing it this is the basic structure of
this kind of game so these games are
complements don't have to have positive
externalities they could also you know
the reason you're doing these things is
because other people are doing it and it
has a negative impact if you don't do it
there's another reason it could happen
this looks like the president
it has a prisoner's dilemma sort of
flavor to it um it's it's it has a
similar structure in the sense that
we're both taking these actions even
though we'd rather not but if the other
person doesn't then we will so it does
it is it has the same strategic
structure as a prisoner's dilemma
yes
well i mean
yeah i mean it's you could transform
this into a prisoner's dilemma um you
could tell the same story as a
this is basically
um not confessing um
doping is is confessing and basically
you both you both end up confessing so
this is it has the same structure as a
prisoner's dilemma yes
so because the loss was denoted l but
also like the difference in the columns
it's just negative c and b minus c is
that supposed to kind of imply that
the or like l is the same magnitude as b
or is that
yeah so here i put for instance um you
know depending on whether
so in terms of analyzing the welfare of
this um
if l is big i sort of put a big arrow
here
often what the stories of doping are
this is that you know effectively you're
put out of competition if you don't do
it and then your loss could be enormous
and so this is a much bigger loss than
sort of the benefits and that's often
the reason that you that it's so hard to
eradicate doping in professional sports
okay in strategic substitutes
um you could have a negative externality
as well
and that's you know sort of your classic
congestion games
so think of uh i'm not going to show up
the other person is not going to show up
so imagine you know we're trying to use
um
one like we're trying to use a printer
um in the same time
if two of us are trying to use it it
congests it so i i don't use it the
other person doesn't use it i get zero
payoff other person doesn't i get a
benefit for it um the negative
externality here is when the other
person shows up
i lose my benefit from actually
using the resource right so there's more
congestion
if we both show up then we lose it so
you know there can be positive or
negative externalities and then the the
complementarities and strategic
substitutes are whether or not my my
relative payoff is bigger or smaller
depending on what the other person wants
to do
so strategic compliments
so complementarities
means that
when you look at
more action from my neighbors compared
to less action
then my
payoff from taking the action has is
relatively larger
right so you look at my relative change
in in uh taking the payoffs from taking
action versus not that gets bigger the
more people uh in the rest of the
population that take it in my
neighborhood and then strategic
substitutes is exactly the opposite
do you also consider settings where
your what happens to you it doesn't
depend only on the neighbors but for
example in the generated fashion on what
happens to the neighborhood neighbors
what if you have weights on the graph
and things like that
yes um so i'll do some examples a little
later on but already these things end up
being tied so here the payoffs aren't
directly tied to that but whether my
neighbor takes that action is dependent
on what
exactly and so for instance if we go
back to these games you know this one
yes of course
it gets even more complex if you have
something
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i'm gonna go through um a
specific continuous action game a little
later where what's gonna happen is my my
benefit's gonna depend on the amount of
action my neighbors take and the amount
of action they take it's gonna depend on
their neighbor's actions and so forth
and then it'll decay so there'll be
indirect effects and we'll actually look
at how your position in the network
determines how much action you take and
you consider sometimes cases where
there's some weights on the edges for
example and yes yeah yeah yeah so we'll
do an example exactly like that we'll do
a special case of that we'll do a linear
quadratic form of that but we'll do a
very um
version where there's going to be
weights and directed and continuous
actions and other dependent
so these sort of simple examples are to
give motivation and basic intuitions
about how payoffs work and so forth and
then we'll get into the worst until i
guess
okay so compliments choices taking
action by my friends increases my
relative payoff to taking it substitutes
the opposite
in compliments there's lots of different
examples of this smoking and other
behavior among teens technology adoption
education learning language corruption
and crime cheating doping etc
substitutes um
information gathering so you know if one
of my friends actually learns to do
something and i can piggyback off them
or free ride off them
then that can be beneficial
students studying and study groups often
if somebody else does the homework
problem then
they don't do it themselves you know so
there's possibilities of that competing
firms
oligopolies with local markets
so
whether or not a firm another firm
enters a market
can cause me damage
vaccinations so this happens and this is
one of the reasons that vaccinations are
very hard near herd immunity you know
once everybody else is vaccinated and
we've gotten hurt immunity my incentive
to vaccinate goes down dramatically
if it's costly or i'm worried about
vaccinating and it's very very hard to
keep a population you know once the the
disease drops to close to zero people
start to tend to start dropping their
vaccinations and then so you get these
kinds of seesaw motions and that can be
reminiscent of a of this kind of
strategic substitutes game
okay useful observations
um compliments
so if you look at my degree and we all
have the same basic structure of payoff
as a function of degrees and neighbors
actions then there's going to be some
threshold such that i prefer to take one
if the number of people in my
neighborhood is above that threshold and
take action zero if it's below that
threshold so in this compliments game
more of my friends taking it the more i
want to take it um substitutes it goes
the opposite way
because up to now um sorted each vertex
has a degree d i and now it's d this
ensemble so average degree of the whole
all right so um this yes so sorry uh
this is a function of the generic degree
but yes it should be a di
yeah exactly so each i look at my degree
and then i i have a threshold that's
based on that and then
if you look at this kind of a threshold
behavior usually there is a single
parameter governing whole uh
say grass
like uh if you talk about the
probability that there might be some
average degree that determines is such a
phenomenon as well for
or given a graph you do kind of
complement whatever it is there's such a
special value independent of the each
vertex
so what you can talk about is
there's partial orderings so what you
end up with is you can end up with uh
statements about whether or something so
let's suppose we ask a question of
here's a technology there's thresholds
for different people adopting it will it
spread
uh you could answer that question you
know and suppose we've got these first
10 people have adopted
depending on what those thresholds look
like as a function of the graph you
might or might not get it but there's
different functions
like
if you look at the eigenvalue it governs
the global parameter yeah yeah yeah i
mean i'll i'll show you some things
we'll get one which will be very closely
related to writing the eigenvalue
eigenvector calculation
but i guess the point here is your
game is defined
also these pairwise
over the network would spread but the
game is just defined on there yeah
exactly so the game each one of these
people is looking at whether what's how
many people in my neighborhood are
taking the action that's all i care
about so i just care about whether or
not my friends are playing the video
games it's really local locally yeah
these are all local games but then these
local games spill over to each other
because whether my friends play it
depends on how many friends they have
and how many of their friends are
adopting it and so forth
now this is sort of
the fact that i mean
it could be that i care about some
diversity or so that's already you have
more than maybe i care that i have sort
of a french which
likes opera
so that i can actually
you can you can have mixed externality
games so you know you have different um
uh you you might you know have positive
or some middle point that you like and
so forth those are even harder to
analyze than these versions will be so
these will be pretty uh
i mean i'm sick enough right if i want
to produce a call right i need sort of i
need an engine i need wheels i need sort
of but having two neighbors which
produce wheels doesn't help
so i need sort of a certain
or if i want to produce
paper i need a social
and the mathematician that
so
yeah yeah so here um
here in this particular specification
that we're talking about so far the
neighbors are generic in the sense that
they're all interchangeable and i just
care about the number so what we've
looked at in terms of these examples so
far was just i care about how many of my
friends but i don't have differences
between my friends and you can also you
know
so this is just a couple of examples
that are going to be useful but you
could label these so that my payoff
depends on which ones of my neighbors
and i get a payoff which is twice as
high if this person takes the action is
this person
you can have interactions between those
so you can specify any payoff function
you want one of these things whether or
not it's going to be tractable to
analyze depends on how you know simple
the game structure is and what kinds of
graph structures we're working with and
so forth
but
you can specify an arbitrary pale
function
have you heard about some of the booster
population
it seems like very much related to
booster population isn't it christian
good strategy
so these these games will have complex
contagion because the whether or not
things are spreading through a
particular neighborhood are going to
depend on people hitting thresholds not
just having one interaction
so it will be exactly bad
okay so um equilibrium existence and
structure
again nash equilibrium every prayers
actions optimal for um that player given
the actions of others
generally we're going to look at what's
known as pure strategy equilibria
meaning people will just take an action
or not or
maybe they have a finite set of actions
i can choose one of three technologies
another possibilities are randomized so
you can have the action spaces be
measures instead of of
you know discrete uh spaces
um in network games often will look for
pure strategy equilibria but sometimes
you need uh these things to be measures
as opposed to
pure strategies
yeah so here's
answer to that question um this is a
very general one take any game specify
whatever payoffs you want
if it has strategic compliments
meaning
that
the if you increase the actions of my
neighbors then my payoff from taking
higher actions goes up
so let's suppose individual strategy
spaces are complete lattices so
everybody has a lattice as an action
space so that means it could be a very
you know
it could be a complex it could be like
taking seven different actions and
taking a whole vector of actions as long
as my payoffs go up
from taking higher actions in this
lattice
as other people take higher actions in
the lattice then the set of pure
equilibria exists it's not empty and it
forms a complete balance so that basic
lattice structure of the games just
comes out of the fact that
complementarities are nicely ordered
games higher actions by other people in
a very broad sense just say they've got
this vector of actions you can increase
that vector i get higher payouts from
taking higher vectors myself
then
everything works and you get
a nice structure to the equilibria it's
going to be non-empty and it's going to
be a complete lattice
okay so complements have really nice
structures for write down whatever
utility function you want for whatever
combinations of of your friends and so
forth you get a nice structure out
so and just for people who don't know
complete lattice every set of equilibria
there exists an x prime such as greater
than or equal to for all of it
and a at least
a greatest lower bound
okay contrast
these games
of complements have really nice
equilibrium structure it's always not
empty games of substitutes well that
best shot public goods game a very
special case
pure strategy equilibrium exists and and
are related to maximum independence sets
but more generally
they might not exist they could it's
possible you get no equilibria because
when the other person wants to take it i
don't and then when i don't you can get
kind of
cycle
games
pure strategy may not exist mixed
strategy will with finite action spaces
and
generally equilibrium will not form uh a
lattice they um when you have
multiplicity they generally won't form a
lattice so do you really need finite
action space so is it not if it's some
i don't know
you can do it with yeah you can do it
with a more general usually this is done
with some kind of space of measures that
have nice continuity properties
and then um so you know
anything so if you go back to coffee
time usually you prove this using copper
tiny six point theorem and so
it's possible to do it in a much more
general space than finite action spaces
okay so uh a couple of questions we can
just ask about let's go back to the
coordination games
um where
i prefer to take action one if some
fraction of people
or more take action one okay so we just
look at this that was the 40 percent
game if at least 40 percent of adopted i
want to adopt it let's look at those
classes of games for just a moment
um what does equilibrium structure look
like well as we said let's let some
group s of the nodes be the people who
have adopted what has to be true
everybody in that group s has to have at
least q of their friends in that group s
a fraction q and everybody outside
has to have at least one minus q of
their friends outside of us in order for
this to to be in equilibrium so it has
to be that the people inside are
satisfying the threshold of people
outside or not
and there's a definition
on a this is sort of an interesting it's
a useful notion beyond this and this was
first defined by steve morrison in the
2000 and he defined the the cohesiveness
of a given group s on a graph g
to be uh we'll say that a group s is r
cohesive if you look at the minimum
fraction of how many people what's the
fraction of friends i have
um inside the group s
if that's bigger than r for everybody in
in s then we'll say that s is at least
our cohesive and then we'll have
the cohesiveness of a group s is just
the minimum
fraction of friends that anybody in that
group has in the set okay so if you just
look at a set of nodes you want to ask
how cohesive it is it's sort of look at
the person who has the fewest fraction
the lowest fraction of their friends in
the group that's the cohesiveness of a
set of nodes
so for instance in this graph
both sets of these both of these two
different sets the reds and greens are
two-thirds cohesive right and so they're
defined by these two nodes or the
critical nodes that have exactly um
two-thirds of their of the friends in
actually there's another couple
okay
so then there exists a pure strategy
equilibrium where both actions are
played in some graph
if and only if there's a group s that's
at least q cohesive and it complements
at least one minus q cohesive
and so what's interesting about this is
this is going to tell us something about
how you cut up a graph
and whether or not a graph can sustain
multiple equilibria is going to depend
on whether you can partition nodes into
sets that are going to have more
connections within those sets than
across so it's going to be related to
community detection the community
detection literature on a graph can we
find communities of nodes that are more
connected internally than across and
that allows these equipment to survive
okay
so here was the 40
if you go through that example
what you can look at is all the
equilibria and actually if you look at
the set of all the equilibria that
divides things into a set of communities
such that there are certain communities
of nodes that are always doing the same
thing no matter what equilibrium you're
looking at right so these were all the
equilibria of that 40 game on this
original graph
you look at the the sigma algebra
generated by that
and that divides up these nodes into
communities
and you can this gives you a foundation
for a certain definition of what a
community is these communities have
enough sustained
fractions inside to always be part of
the same equilibrium but then you get
cuts across there
okay
so this is one way of dividing and
identifying communities in a graph so
from the game you can define the
communities in the graph
these minimal communities
yeah so actually what this this does
this helps in two things one is if you
want to do an algorithm for
calculating different equilibria
identifying these communities can help
in terms of figuring out what the
equilibria are
it also helps in seeking algorithms
so if i want to start getting a behavior
to take off and i know what the
communities are i know that they're
going to
behave the same i can say okay look i
want to get people playing this video
game
what's the best way to you know start
this out i can start by by getting
certain communities activated and seeing
what else happens but if i understand
equilibrium structure and i understand
what the structures look like then
that's helpful in a bunch of different
solving a bunch of different problems
so this gives a definition of
communities in terms of what
so i don't know how many people know the
community in texas literature but
there's a community detection literature
out there which is based on different
ways of cutting up a graph and saying
these look like the nodes that belong
together because they're really densely
connected internally and not so
connected across
these games give you a concrete way of
defining that because these are the you
know the equilibrium structure divides
that graph up in terms of what the
communities are going to be
okay and one thing that's different is
this was the set for q equals point four
it turns out if you have any q between
one third and a half
right at a half things can go kind of
haywire because of integer constraints
but you know or between a half and
two-thirds these will be the communities
the the equilibrium splitting of the
graph will be the same
okay so let me re-ask my question from
before
if you have these groups which have to
stick together
what does
um so in terms of lattice structure
remember the lattice
uh what that means is they're always the
same color in every element of the lens
so it doesn't it doesn't mean so the
lattice itself is a lattice over graph
of
sets of equilibria
so you can still be that they're always
acting the same even though they are
never in equilibrium alone because
anytime they're all taking it then these
other two people are also taking it
so you can't have these people taking it
without these people also taking the
action
so they always act the same but that
doesn't mean that they can sort of be a
self-sustaining community where they're
the only people taking the action
um
so what's interesting about this is
different behaviors give you different
splits of the graph
so a 40 threshold
game is different from
you know one that takes something less
than a third and bigger than a quarter
this is one where i need fewer i have a
lower threshold of friends before i'm
going to take this action right so this
is a better technology if at least you
know 25 of my friends take it i'm
willing to take it um that
ends up with equilibria that are bigger
in this particular case
and that ends up with a different split
of the graph
so depending on what behavior you have
you could have different possibilities
emerging for how the graph splits up
and then you know once q is really
really low or really really high
basically it's impossible to get
different people in different parts of
the graph taking it if the threshold is
so low that once any one of my friends
takes that i'm going to take it then
things are going to spread through the
whole graph then a simple contagion
right so this is simple contagion either
the whole graph gets infected or not at
all
is there any threshold cues so that
our stay in one component
whatever this complimentary strategy
it's different question can you pin down
depending on the grasping yeah yeah so
if you get so
generally it's hard so
one way to let me see if i can
understand the question give me a graph
and then like give me some part of the
graph and say is there a cue where i
could get this part activated and
nothing else or
as a whole here i i see that there's
there is no chance to have cut right
right right
yeah
according to the strategy that we are
building up there should be some queue
oh right right right yeah exactly so
what is here it's one quarter so what's
the queue
which doesn't complement yeah yeah yeah
right yeah well one minus q is there a
unique value so they give an improve i
can characterize either due to the
second eigenvalue or the first
eigenvalue whatever yeah so i can answer
that question for stochastic block
models but don't know the answer
generally
so for certain classes of graphs there's
a well-defined answer which is the
minimum probability of connection across
components but i don't know what the
answer is for uh
yeah because it's it's it's more com
it's more complex than a uh an expansion
property because it
yeah um
but there might be a relationship
between some expander graph properties
right right sugar constant or
yeah the problem in general
is related to the densest subdraft
problem so yeah that makes it a
difficult problem approximately yeah
yeah so yeah
but you know when you assume you have a
random graph model some of these things
become useful exactly so for stochastic
block models then you can answer these
questions because you know exactly what
the densities are going to be
approximately in the limit but more
generally i don't know of any
simple way of
encapsulating that
okay so let's uh just a quick theorem on
stochastic block models um so let's
think of we've
um christian talked about stochastic
block models this morning so we've got a
bunch of different blocks these are
people who are going to
have certain characteristics for
instance
you know these are people who are more
likely to connect to each other
possibly probability of links from block
b to b prime just depends on whether
you're in b and b prime not on anything
else about the nodes so the blocks are
enough to determine these probabilities
we'll let this vary with the size of the
graph
and let the expected degree of a node in
group block b
to
nodes in block b prime be some number so
this is the expected number of
connections i'm going to have if i'm um
you know from stanford to people in
berkeley this would be my expected
degree
okay and then overall expected degree is
there's a degree for um expected degree
for somebody in each block
and
this is just the first peach size of
support
exactly i mean first well this is this
one is actually my overall degree so
it's
yeah yeah so this is just
this is this times the size of group b
prime
yeah
and then this one is going to be the sum
over all these across the different um
okay what we're going to assume
is that this is at least one plus
epsilon log n so that the graph you know
that at least these blocks are going to
be connected components so we won't have
splits within the within the blocks
almost surely as the graph grows
okay so that's a large stochastic block
model but these probabilities could be
arbitrarily
varying across these things as long as
they satisfy this minimum connectedness
within a block and the blocks could be
of different sizes etc so that's a large
stochastic block model
we'll say it's convergent
if
um sorry not large k this should be
large n
if the eventually there's some fixed set
number of blocks
and
the relative
connectedness that
a node has from b to b prime compared to
its overall degree converges to some
number so relatively how connected
somebody in block b is to block b prime
is a well-defined limit
okay so we'll say it's convergent if
that's true
that's clear so just we've got a fixed
set of blocks and eventually these
relative probabilities are converging
nicely
and
we're going to bring in homophily and i
don't know how many people know what
homophobia is i'm going to talk a lot
about homophily tomorrow homophily is
the tendency of people with similar
characteristics to
connect more to themselves than to other
people
will say that so you know
when we look at high school students
they'll be heavily segregated by age by
gender etc
weekly homophilus is going to say that
the relatively chance that a b person
has connecting to a b person is higher
than a b prime person connecting to a b
person
okay by some epsilon yet another story
this detailed question this is a g d d
the degree between blocks divided by
within converges
is this universal uh
uh it converges to one single thing for
every or for each for each for each pair
it converges to something yeah yeah so
just for each bb prime pair
yeah sorry so it doesn't converge to the
same thing but for all b and b prime
this thing converges
exactly
they could be very heterogeneous in
terms across these things but we have a
well defined
that for instance you know if we look at
um
you know
math majors and statistics majors and
computer science majors and we're
looking at the fraction of math majors
with statistics majors friendships that
doesn't have to be the same as math
majors with computer science majors so
we have those friendship groups
there's likelihoods and weekly
homophilus just means that computer
scientists are more likely to be friends
with computer scientists than
mathematicians are to be with computer
scientists
so there's sufficient foundation for
what perhaps that seems just if your
block matters would just scale with some
function of end globally yes yeah it's a
group size as possible
the ratios converge but you could have
that for example one group gets smaller
and smaller but the connectivity gets
bigger and bigger it makes up for it
yeah yeah so could you have a
limit in this setting where the limit
one who has only one person
instead that's the limit
um
yeah i mean you have to allow self loops
uh
all right no um no no no you can't
because this previous the overall
expected degree inside each group is at
least
log n so you have to have uh at least
log n nodes in each group
um yeah so there's going to be a lower
bound on the sides of each movement
okay um this is a clear actually
uh
neutral to an old paper
so take a growing sequence of stochastic
block networks
any sequence of sets of adopters that
are equilibrium for some open set of
queue so makes look at at people
adopting a technology and let's make
sure so what does open set of q mean
when you take integer numbers like a
half
um
in graphs there's a lot of times where
people have even numbers of friends and
you know like a half causes problems so
jiggle it and make sure it's also in
equilibrium for a half plus some epsilon
and a half minus some epsilon so it's
not just a knife edge case so as long as
you have equilibria that are somewhat
robust in that sense
then
in the limit they're going to be a
superset of the blocks with a
probability going to one so whenever you
look at a stochastic block model the set
of equilibria when we're thinking about
who are those nodes that are always
acting the same basically the blocks
will be the set of nodes that are always
acting the same
and it doesn't say that
you know each block is in equilibrium it
just says that the equilibrium are going
to be supersets of those blocks so it
could be the two blocks are heavily
connected to each other and they always
act the same
but um
they're you're not going to get a
subdivision of a block okay
so you're not going to end up having
things split across a block
and if the sequence of block models is
convergent and weakly haemophilus then
you can find some cues
for which any particular block is an
equilibrium for those q with a
probability going to one
so
uh you know when once you have this
convergence property then you can
actually
isolate and make sure that some block is
in equilibrium
for some particular cube yes
um
yeah so
the community of detection here is is
um
so
effectively there is a phase transition
uh
what the
what the
size of this is in terms of these
probabilities
the proof underlyingness relies on
churnoff bounds and so you can get a
rate of convergence on exactly how
quickly this happens as a function of
the number of nodes and the density
but it's a sharp transition it's a very
sharp transition so basically what
happens is um below some uh
some end you'll get that these things
split almost always and then above it
you'll get the
yeah
so
if you if you have that right maybe it
will over the epsilon slightly decreases
this thing
probably be a threshold right so there
are some questions will that be a sharp
threshold so maybe there are some
right so epsilon states like square root
of one over square root of everything i
mean
yeah fine but different scales so
i i think it's um
[Music]
yeah it's going to be
a concentration balance probably will
have some power which you can no longer
but that is not that doesn't mean that
the other day
yeah i don't know exactly what it means
so is this a weekly homophilia uh
conditions yeah
the case where you had um
where you had those
three that couldn't act alone yeah who
always came along for the ride
is is that the situation for this to be
exactly a good point yeah this is
violated in that example what's
happening is those two um have half of
their friends and we move forward with
three and so they mean you can't get the
three so what this is this allows is the
b people to be separated away from the
decline people and if the b prime people
are also connecting into the b people at
a high rate then there's no chance to
separate that block out that's exactly
what's happening
and so those three always brought along
those two because those two had
friendships in there half their friends
in that group and so if you have like a
group which might be very cohesive but
then if there's some other group that
has all their friendships and you've got
to throw them into
right in the in the spectral cuts
there's this cut-off phenomenon
depending on the rate at which episode
goes to zero we saw that you can or
can't say i could can't or can't detect
this so i guess there's a mathematical
question at least whether those cutoffs
are the same or different in this
different
uh
game you know different yeah yeah i
think the analogy is a good one i mean
and i don't know exactly where the
resolution of this is
um i mean i can tell you so
let me tell you where the how we figured
out eventually the group is so we found
this theorem by
dirmid and
and um
stermin which
basically what it shows is look at an
erdos ringy random graph
look at the modularity of them what's
the modularity the modularity of a graph
is okay partition the set of nodes into
a couple of pieces or however many
pieces you want
and then look at relatively
how many
of the links are inside those
elements of the partition inside those
groups
compared to what would happen if you put
the same links down at random in the
graph
right
so it's sort of modular if somehow it
looks like these groups have more links
than they should relative to what a just
a purely random process would be that's
the modularity and so what the what they
proved is if you have an erdos or any
random graph you're not going to find
any cuts in that graph where you've got
too many connections inside the
different parts of the partition
compared to what you should have at a
random so that's a
it's a theorem and i would you know
you when sometimes you conjecture
something you think oh that's for sure
true but i have no idea how to prove it
this one i could say yeah maybe maybe
it's true maybe it's not um but this
turns out to be true
to p isn't it dependent on p um the p
has to be at least the log n so we're
we're at least in this range where it's
at least
log n over n
um so you have to have the minimum
connectedness of this but above it's
actually um
a little bigger than that but yeah you
need some connectiveness conditions
and then you get this you get this
so then to your question if probably
then you are in the detection actually
yeah so so the reason that this is i
think that this is
why is this strong
modularity of a graph going to zero
means that basically there's no way that
you could have you know when you've sort
of accidentally thrown down this rash or
any random graph there's no cut you can
find that doesn't look like the the
links within compared to a cross just
looked like they're
still matching the random
proportions that they should they're
still pretty much p within and p across
and that means that you know and there's
a lot of cuts you can be making right so
you can make exponentially different
numbers of cuts here so the fact that
none of those are showing much
modularity is the strength of this
theorem and so once you have that then
that says these blocks are really going
to operate like groups of nodes that are
always going to act the same because
they really are going to look exactly
the same in terms of their graph
properties
and so you know you just show that the
equilibrium splits if if an equilibrium
splits some block then the modularity
has to have uh be bonded away from zero
and that can't be happening if this
theorem is true
but is your guarantee per vertex so you
when you say it doesn't split any block
even you know it's not possible there's
like five of the vertices exactly so
that's why it's it's yeah it's the uh
and that's coming from the fact that
when this p is high enough and you look
at the turnoff bounds
with a probability going to one
almost every so there's alumni you have
to prove in this almost every node in
the block has
the same expected degrees within a
certain ratio of everybody else so
there's nobody that ends up looking
different from anybody else
so i have one um you had a first
condition is that condition necessary
for the do you have an example that
shows
this one the first one there is any
sequence yes
yeah so any sequence of adopters that
are equilibrium for some open set of q
are superstar blocks
yeah so what's the condition
but there's no condition on this part
right
oh yeah the open set yeah so the problem
is if you hit the major constraints like
a half you can get um you can get this
up yeah you can get uh from then you can
get a
like really well balanced block where it
splits because half the p you know
we all have half our friends in it wow
but like some of us take the action some
don't because we're exactly different at
a half so it's it's a difference in the
half is the problem
another question the second thing
this existential statement they exist
there exists some purpose of q can you
uh
pin down yeah yeah so this is done by um
construction
so it's actually done by identifying the
set of cube for which this does and it
relates to these relative probabilities
in the blocks so you can figure out
exactly what those queues are yes and
what's who is s and the js
oh this is um
storms evan storms who's a student a phd
student at uh
um q is that probability or sorry this
threshold so we're thinking about these
games where this is the 40 or 50 or
whatever so as you vary that threshold
you get different properties of the
graph and then
in terms of equilibrium
okay other results there's lots of i
mean so this is just like a
you know a quick dive into a little bit
of games on networks um there's
community structures you can do from
this seating you can do
complex contagion you know damon sintolo
has a whole book on this there's not
that much that's well understood i think
you know about the
properties of some of the complex
contagion yet and i think that this is
one hope we're talking at lunch about
where graphon games can be useful um
there's some possibilities that graph
like some of the work that paris and
azdar and others have been doing
could be useful in actually
understanding complex contagion on these
you know equilibrium can be ordered by
degree distributions again graph on
games might be very helpful here so you
can look at these you know you can do
games on graphons as well as games on
networks and then you can begin to
understand these properties and then
that can give you limiting theorems on
what the structure of the equilibrium
might look like along the sequence
different groups have their own mixed
strategies
yeah i mean so so each each node is
choosing a strategy and now i want an
equilibrium to be i'm best responding to
the strategies of the set of people that
i'm uh connected to and i get a payoff
which is an integral of the over the set
of modes of you know the actions of that
so everything's just should be done by
integration as opposed to like looking
at 40 of my friends that was 40 of the
of the friends i had in the graphine and
i want to take the actions at least 40
just as my graph on friends do you want
one thing
[Music]
in sort of extending our understanding
and some of these things
um
so this is the ad health data set i know
people know that health so this was
connected in the 1990s it's a bunch of
high school data collected in the u.s
but they have a bunch of
behaviors on the network as well so
smoking other kinds of things and you
can look at the networks and then you
can look at the behaviors and you can
see whether or not they seem to follow
one of these network games so another
thing instead of actually trying to
calculate all the possible equilibria is
say well let's look at this so this is
the actual one of these networks the
these pink nodes are smokers the blue
ones are non-smokers and you can ask
what
game what q would actually rationalize
this as an equilibrium so if you wanted
to say this is an equilibrium where you
adopt you smoke if at least cube percent
of your friends smoke and you don't to
fewer
what would be the cue that would
actually fit this particular network
okay so if you in what you you know
you're gonna get some wrong because here
for instance is a smoker who's
surrounded entirely by non-smokers so
there's some people whose behavior
you're not going to be able to explain
by by a game um so you're going to get
some errors and the question is what's
the cue that has the fewer fewest errors
so just look for the queue that has the
fewest number of people who are doing
the wrong thing in the network
okay i can see that for you all
i do is saying you should not because
you can't but in reality you will be
positive some people are sort of more
artistic
yeah exactly so what this is doing is
not saying that this is it is at all
what might be happening in terms of
these people's behaviors there's
probably a lot of heterogeneity but what
we could ask is how close can we get to
fitting this
you know so first of all what's the best
fit cue it's 0.39
so 39 if at least 39 percent of your
friends smoke then you smoke fewer than
you don't
um it mispredicts about a little less
than 30 of what they use so that's
better than 50 right but it's not much
better um so it's getting but it means
that there's a lot of energy
so one question would be okay well now
let's suppose we put in demographics and
we have different thresholds for people
who for instance have more siblings or
people who have fewer siblings or people
who are from different um you know
income distributions or you know there's
a bunch of different characteristics we
know about these nodes you can put in
different thresholds from them and then
begin to see if you can flip this
histogram
yeah yeah exactly so the way you do this
is just counting because it's a pure so
it's really simple but it's just saying
that looking at these things from this
being theoretic perspective gives you a
way of then trying to back out what's
the game that people are playing as a
function and it's exactly a histogram is
the right way to to do these counts you
just look at the overlapping histogram
and see how many people you've
miscounted
yeah
so but how do you know people are not
changing they're friends like they're
cooler ones who smoke actually yeah yeah
um
so answer to that so
uh we've been collecting data at
we had four years of data at cal tech
and now we have three years of data at
stanford and we are following people
over time and they're seeing their
changes and friendships and their
changes and behaviors
and it appears that both go on
so i mean there's no other literature on
this too of co-evolution and
there's an empirical literature that
looks at this but both are happening
here so you do see people changing their
behavior in response to what their
friends are doing but you also see
people changing their friends and so
it's quite possible that people you know
are making friends through the smoking
as opposed to
um so so so i'm not saying that this is
a good valid you know empirical exercise
go ahead and start estimating you know
smoking gains this way but what it does
say is that you know if once we
understand some of the game theory it
could potentially be a tool where you
can take it to estimation if you know
enough about the game and you know
enough about the structure of the
incentives and so forth um but
clearly both things are going on the
network is not random here it's it's
adjusting to the behaviors
so do you actually have any results
about consistency like if you have one
of these network games in any situation
this is on the ad health data which is
real data right but if the data were
actually generated from some model and
you played a game and i gave you the
outcome of that is there a result saying
you can actually
consistently estimate the parameters of
the game
[Music]
techniques so we actually have three
different techniques for estimating it
and we do we
prove that those are going to be
consistent estimators under certain
properties of the networks so um i can
send you the appendix on that
okay is that sorry in epidemiology
people have looked at civil networks
model where let's say you have an effort
on gmp
but if i see that i mean is infected i
would say oh that's too risky i'd be
buyer to somebody else's background
and
so
maybe i'm a small but i'm the only small
of all these friends which don't smoke
maybe under some social media
environment
there might be simple models
yeah yeah definitely i think you know
developing good models of co-evolution
of both the actions and the network and
people's decisions on whether
to change their behavior or change the
network are the ones that are important
and
not well
well there's a few examples out there
when is it that we think that accounting
for these sort of interdependencies and
behavior is important as opposed to just
some sort of more mechanical model yeah
um i have sort of two answers to that
one is i
i think the
the
um
understanding what model i would want to
write down for that dynamic
can also come from a game theoretic
model so
but part of the way we've analyzed stuff
is sort of at equilibrium but instead
you could just do a dynamic where it
says okay look i just wait till i adopt
until 40 of my friends do and now you
know start the process moving and then
just sort of study the dynamics that's a
well-defined dynamic and we can study it
and and so the equilibrium itself isn't
necessarily the object we need to study
these also have interesting dynamic
processes and like the whole agent-based
modeling literature is is based off of
of that to some extent and and so i
think that that that's an important you
know ingredient here and
um just some of the equilibria structure
gives us benchmarks to understanding and
and you know i think part of the reason
for going through all this is not so
much that it it's you know that we want
to use these for add health and so forth
but it gives us a broader understanding
of when externalities might be present
um why things might be getting stuck and
we're not getting past some certain
amount of of adoption how would we go
about so one you know thing that comes
across here is okay well if these groups
and i know somehow that that these
groups correspond possibly to blocks
then if i do want to intervene i might
want to intervene by putting a bunch of
seeds
if i can have a program maybe i target a
bunch of people in the same block
because if i spread my seeds all over
it's not going to do anything but if i
can get one block activated then maybe
all those people you know i get enough
people in that block that turns on the
block so i think it's just you know
broader understandings understanding the
externalities the the welfare so the
other nice thing here is there's
actually payoffs associated with this
so at the end of the day you can say you
know are people better off or worse off
than they would be in some other
equilibrium which is the best
equilibrium so we can do those kinds of
orderings so i think that that's an
advantage of this kind of model
um but it comes at some cost right so
it's you know
but i think that that's those are the
sort of nice things about it um but it
certainly lends itself to dynamics as
well
okay
um now to the promised one with weights
and uh and so forth i'll just do a quick
version of this
so there's let's look at a linear
quadratic models this this model comes
from baluster cal barman golem is new in
2006.
um so what we have is people are
choosing an action
some xi each person is choosing this and
now let's think of this as a real number
so this is how much i'm studying how
much crime i'm doing uh how how many
years i stay um in school
etc so it's some intensity
and
the the structure is
and now i'm in a graph and this is the
weight that i have on jay
and this could be weighted and it could
be directed so i could be you know
somebody maybe i pay attention to and
they don't care who i am right they
don't care what i do they don't even
know my name but i pay attention to them
so it could be directed it could be
weighted
and so forth and the structure of this
is such that i have some direct benefit
from the action
um so this is the linear part linear
here and it's going to be linear here
the quadratic part is
i've got a quadratic cost so i'm not
going to take an infinite amount of this
action this kills the action off at some
level
so it's costly to take increasing
amounts of the action
and then there's this
social part and the social part is that
i get some benefit
from the amount
that i take the action which depends
on how much the other person's taking
the action so
more weight on some friend and more
action by that friend gives me a higher
marginal benefit to taking higher
actions myself okay so that's this so
i've got these
interactions between people and that is
increasing in the amount of action that
they're taking
um so these will take take them to be
non-negative real numbers
but they could be potentially infinite
and what's going to happen is we're
going to have to have conditions on how
big b is
compared to c and and how it relates to
the eigenvalue of this matrix in order
to make sure that this thing is going to
be well defined and not run off to
infinity
[Music]
yeah
okay so that's the model really simple
and now you just say okay let's maximize
this function so taking is given what
everybody else is doing what does a
different person want to do
well you know just differentiate set
equal to zero so you get the x i is some
function of a plus b
times the sum of the x weighted actions
of my friends divided by c so it's a
really beautiful model in terms of its
simplicity which is part of the reason
it's taken off in terms of applications
so in matrix form
x equals a plus gx
where the a is just the a overseas
and the g is the b times g over c and
this answers christian's question so
when does this have a nice solution
um
well you know you can write this in two
different ways you could write this as x
is equal to the sum of the g k's times a
or x is equal to i minus g inverse a if
it's invertible
um when is this going to be true
so
this is going to be this is going to
have a nice
well basically the solution uh you're
going to have to have the eigenvalue of
this
um this is the b over c has to be uh
less than one right so it's going to
for the stable converge so make sure
that it's the maximum if you have to
look at the secondary
yes
yeah
yeah so there's a whole series of papers
that give conditions on
um on you know for more general versions
of these games when you get nice
solutions when we get a nice
maximum solution
so there can be multiple points in these
things this particular game is simpler
than that but
okay nice thing about this
is that
if you look at this
so look at this x
function
you can actually write out what the
solution of x looks like
it actually looks like one plus the sum
of this g case
right
um times a over c
this is what's known as cat's bonuses
centrality in the network's limit
right so cat's bonuses centrality what
you do is you count your
direct you know sort of your direct
connections
your indirect connections you look at
all the locks in the network
and then you weight those by sort of
this decay factor
and
um
the basically what's what's true that is
my behavior
looks like a over c which is sort of
what i would do on all on my
my own in this game without any
interactions plus something which
depends on my centrality in the network
and so people who are more central in
the network take higher behavior
right and why is that it's because they
have more neighbors and those neighbors
are also that they have more neighbors
and so forth so cat's finances
centrality is looking at what's the sort
of weighted walk that they have that
goes away from me
i'm getting i get more behavior from
that and then they get more behavior
from that so this is bringing in that
indirect um and it just comes out in a
very simple formula where um this is
just the bottom reminds me of that
but it seems to be slightly different
oh yeah so um page rank so there's three
related concepts page rank um bonuses
centrality and architecture centrality
bonuses centrality
so
page rank
generally you're going to have a
specification where you take a random
walk in the network but then you also
occasionally take um jumps
it's like a jump yes so
uh but if you look just at the bonuses
centrality it would be like doing
pagerank without um in a connected graph
without any without any jumps
and then this
i don't know the precise relationship
between this one plus part with
okay so this is a you know natural
feedback
it captures the network
um
centrality pops out of this naturally
there's been a bunch of applications of
this so patakini and zanu did this on
criminal behavior
calvo patakini engineer did study habits
i actually have a paper we've looked at
politically political efforts in the u.s
congress
based on the network structure
corporate control drug trafficking
you can do stuff on teen behavior
so there's a bunch of different
applications you can
do with this model because it relates
centrality to behavior in a very
easy intractable way now again it's kind
of heroic to assume that this is the
right model behind what's actually
happening in terms of behavior but you
can put in a lot of heterogeneity and
yeah yeah
now uh
let's talk about that off stop uh yeah
it's not exactly related but it's
um but one more generally
you can put in
individual specific parameters on all
these things to fit the model um if you
want to take it to data can you comment
a little bit then you say when you talk
about applications how do economists use
this model so this is for predicting
behavior for predicting
yeah explaining
let me give you one example then really
quickly on that
um so here's the kelvin product
so they applied this to add health and
they looked at um they add health data
you have how many hours you study and
then you have the network and then you
have how many hours your friends stood
and then the idea was that they thought
that there'd be complementarities and
warrior friends studied the more you
would study and so then they estimated
this and what they did is they just
literally took this
you know this equilibrium
so now you have a prediction of what
each x should be as a function of a c
and then implicit and this is the b's
and so what you can do is you can just
say okay here's the actual network
here's the actual studies habits what
are the a b and c
and then they could look and so what
they did was say they estimated b over c
to be point five five it doesn't mean
election is that big i don't know
but what what it does is
a standard deviation increase in bonuses
centrality
increases your study habits um by about
seven percent
so it gives you an idea of
people who are more central in this
study network
study higher and there's a certain
percentage of study that you know you
can come up with that was awesome
no no this isn't causal at all um so we
have no idea so so this is the
structural modeling which means you know
we take the model we take it to data we
try and see what happens and this is if
this were if this model was really
happening then this would be the
expected output this does not mean
necessarily that if you take a student
and give them different connections and
give them a higher bonuses centrality
they're going to study more you can do
instruments for some of the behaviors
and try and get causal stuff out but
that's a lot more complicated so if i
have more friends that would increase my
message
that means i want to study
it depends on whether your friends are
studying more right
so this is kind of
centrality in the study network not
necessarily
in terms of a friendly network
since this there's been a lot on you
trying to use get causal estimates of
seeding and influence
yeah yeah i mean i think that you know
there are ways to do that so
just taking the models purely at face
value is somewhat heroic but i think
they give us insights to what's going on
they help us understand what policies we
might or might you know try um and so
forth but then we can try to do things
and get causal influences
so i think that these models
any model we write down is a useful tool
right and we have to understand what
we're using it for and why we're using
it and when we can take it seriously
and
i think what it does do in terms of
empirical work is to offer some
discipline into exactly so the standard
the alternative kind of peer effects
models would be just to run regressions
on these things right you just regress
uh a given person on your friends and
what you can do is you can look at okay
if you just did the usual thing where
you regress how much somebody studies on
what their friends are doing how much
better fit do you may actually get from
this one
and you do get a better fit so so if you
look in in what they did you get a much
better fit from this model than you do
from just a straight regression model so
compared to just doing you know simple
regressions of pure effects you you do
better now what the ground truth is then
requires us to somehow get you know
random studying
you know done so you maybe you can go in
and do a field experiment now so now we
have a model that we can use we can go
do a field experiment and see if we can
get some things out and that's some you
know there's there's studies of some of
the learning and other kinds of things
using field experiments where you
randomly tweak people's behaviors and
then you can see the adjustments and
behaviors of others and you can see
whether they match up with these models
so i think those allow you to get some
causal inference out then i had a
question and let's see if we can hold
this because it's forgetting closely
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think i mean
there's a are you going to say a bunch
of other things but i won't so there's
lots of externality uh
applications i think the externalities
are important to understand so just
conceptually understanding that means
that you know individual incentives and
societal welfare are going to diverge we
didn't talk a lot about policies but you
know in these kinds of gains we have
externalities it does mean that you know
increasing somebody's study could
benefit the the other people around them
and so there's um you know sub-optimal
performance in these games like the
prisoners dilemma kinds of features and
other kinds of things that we need to
understand
and they do have systematic features
that can be quantified
in terms of games
there's a whole like this is like one
piece of the literature is games on that
works and then as christian was asking
and other people were asking as well
the network
forms endogenously as well
and you can use game theory to
understand that right so
maybe i prefer to connect with other
smokers compared to non-smokers
what's going to happen if i have that
preference how is the network going to
evolve so there's a whole literature
that uses game theoretic models to
that's actually how i got started in
networks was modeling network formation
rather than games on networks so you can
use game theoretic techniques to study
that as well so there's a lot of you
know possibilities for these kinds of
approaches um and then they can be used
businesses so tomorrow
i'm going to talk i'll talk a bit more
about homophily and i'll show you some
data on homophily and how split networks
are and then
show you some
implications of that and then we'll look
at a learning model where we can
understand how the splits in a network
actually affect speed of of information
transmission in the network
so i think that's right on time
hopefully if that clock's right then
uh time for coffee
[Applause]
so even better you have the reception
perception great